Thank You mr. chairman I want to also
thank Howard Baker for taking time to be
here a man of uncommon wisdom my son
come also has uncommon wisdom he decided
to change career streams when he was at
Stanford instead of going to law school
ended up with a PhD in statistics so
when I started law school to tell you
how the world changes I'm 63 years old
when I got out of law school
schoolteachers earned more than
beginning lawyers sometimes as we wish
the ways of the past were to return one
of the favorite sayings of former Chief
Justice Earl Warren was that one person
and the truth is a majority it is from
this perspective that I speak today as
one person who in the court of rural
opinion has led the defense of the truth
about the assassination the defense of
the warrant Commission and the defense
of Earl Warren a jurist whose integrity
was above reproach a man who has become
a 1990s victim of a version of
McCarthyism at one time Earl Warren was
best known for his leadership in
breaking down the barriers of
discrimination and the landmark decision
of Roundy Board of Education
but today America's young people know
him best as he is portrayed in the one
brothers film JFK as a liar as an
incompetent and as someone who
participated in a cover-up of the truth
about the assassination of President
Kennedy what far right-wing extremists
try to persuade a majority of Americans
to believe in the 1960s with their
impeach Earl Warren billboards Hollywood
has been able to achieve in the 1990s
and it's impeachment of the integrity of
a great Chief Justice Earl Warren is not
the only victim the Kennedy
assassination is called a coup d'etat a
public execution by elements of the CIA
in the department of defense while
president lyndon b johnson is called an
accessory after the fact in other words
a murderer
when a film not only alleges conspiracy
but names the guilty parties it goes
beyond just artistic license
entertainment it crosses the threshold
of slander and character assassination
and as if killing and as if telling
these lies are not enough one of others
has now gone one step further and is
help financing the mailing of thirteen
thousand copies of a JFK study guide to
high school studies and social history
social studies history departments and
colleges the text supposedly has been
approved by Warner Brothers that is
accompanied by a film poster and a
two-page exercise sheet and hopefully
the they'll be able to sell a lot of
videos that way all of this is in the
context of a film that professes to
speak the truth dedicated to the young
and whose spirit the truth for the in
whose spirit the search for the truth
marches on declares the film at the end
the truth is the most important value we
have proclaims Kevin Costner as he
portrays New Orleans District Attorney
Jim Garrison in fact to incorporate JFK
in any school curriculum misrepresents
the truth the same way that Joseph
Goebbels misrepresented the truth as he
cranked up the propaganda machine for
Nazi Germany bringing disinformation
into the media and into the classrooms
of German schools if you want to
understand the tools of the trade of
Warner Brothers
stone and Custer in perpetrating their
massive fraud remember the letters M o
LD which stands for the acronym mold
misrepresentations omissions lies and
dollars perhaps the best place to begin
to understand how devious are the
misrepresentations of JFK is to examine
the words of mr. stone in his attacks on
the Warren Commission and I might add on
me the March 9 issue of New York
magazine published a letter written by
stone with the help of the hill a note
and public relations agency the people
with BCCI and also received more than
ten million dollars from the Kuwait
government help spread this information
mr. stohn cited in this primary quote
consensus Authority supporting his
attacks in the warrant remission the
1979 report of the House Select
Committee on assassinations but Oliver
Stone deliberately covered up the fact
that the House panels all over the
conclusion on page 41 of the report was
and I quote Lee Harvey Oswald fired
three shots at President John F Kennedy
two shots hit one shot missed that's
exactly what the Warren Commission found
and is diametrically opposite to mr.
stone and GfK versions of the truth
where supposedly Lee Harvey Oswald
didn't kill anyone and there were three
different gunmen with the Warner
Brothers film calls triangulation JFK
claims that the shot that killed
President Kennedy was fired from the
front the House committees report on
page 43 directly contradicts this as did
the Warren Commission concluding and a
quote that President Kennedy was struck
by two and only two bullets each of
which entered from the rear that's what
mr. stones Authority says the house
committee's report further concluded
that notwithstanding the backward
movement of President Kennedy's head and
body in the Zapruder film after the
fatal shot struck the central focus of
the movie and television attacks on the
Warren Commission findings and now I
quote again there is no medical evidence
that the president was struck by a
bullet entering the front of the head
and the second bullet which hit
President Kennedy I quote again caused a
massive wound to the president's head
upon exit expert testimony showed and I
quote again that nerve damage from a
bullet entering the president's head
could have caused his back muscles to
tighten which in turn could have caused
this had to move toward the rear the
phenomenon was demonstrated in a filmed
experiment which involved the shooting
of goats these goats by the way because
there are dog lovers and horse lovers
but evidently not many goat lovers in
the country also like the Warren
Commission the House committees report
on the basis of the findings of its
medical panel and on the basis of
neutron activation analysis and I'm
going to quote again concluded that a
single bullet passed through both
President Kennedy and governor Connally
on this question which has been called
the most controversial issue in the
Warren Commission report which JFK
claims couldn't happen the House
committees and I quote again forensic
pathology panelists conclusion were
consistent with a so-called single
Bullet theory advanced by the Warren
Commission what about the murder of
Dallas police officer JD Tippit what
I've called the rosetta stone to
understanding the truth about the
assassination of President Kennedy JFK
asserts that Oswald was a patsy and did
not do it but like the Warren Commission
the House report concluded and I quote
that Oswald shot and killed officer
Tippit the committee further concluded
that and I'm quoting again this crime
committed while fleeing the scene of the
assassination was consistent with the
finding that Oswald assassinated the
president the fundamental differences
between the committee's report in the
Warren Commission's findings stem
primarily from purported acoustical
evidence involving oscillating ways made
from an examination of a cassette tape
of a Dallas police radio recording the
House Committee split on this issue
the majority claimed that this evidence
indicated the presence of a second
gunman who missed everything if you were
actually down in Dallas to see where it
was you could almost impossibly miss
everything
shooting downhill 125 feet away and miss
not just the occupants of a limousine
but the presidential limousine itself
the the descent of the minority was
vindicated when this acoustical evidence
was subsequently disproved by the May 14
1982 report of the committee of
ballistic acoustics of the National
Research Council it was chaired by
Professor Norman Ramsey of the Harvard
Physics Department which found no
scientific validity for moreover the
1982 definitive study further found that
the point on the tape were oscillating
waves supposedly indicated the sounds of
another shot actually occurred on the
tape more than one minute after the
assassination there you have an essence
the scruples and deception of mr. stone
he attacks the Warren Commission siding
against his
authority the House Committee report as
if it disagreed with the identification
of özil as a lone gunman when in fact
the committee's report corroborated the
conclusions of the Warren Commission
that Lee Harvey Oswald was a lone gunman
who killed President Kennedy would
governor kylie and killed officer given
the revisionist history of JFK combines
these kinds of misrepresentations with
wholesale omissions of critical evidence
and testimony as the producers and
actors weave their web of deceit
for instance the movie covers up the
single most important witness to the
assassination Howard Brennan who
actually saw the gunman fire from the
southeast corner window of the
sixth-floor School Book Depository
building he called us to the attention
of the police when officers went to that
window they found three cartridge cases
at a large paper bag used to carry the
rifle into the building the bag had
Oswald's palm print and finger print but
don't ever see Brennan or the cartridge
cases or the paper bag with a palm
pricks palm print of Oswald and a finger
prints in JFK another example of the
emissions and JFK involves the six
eyewitnesses who saw the gunman at the
tippet murder scene or running away from
the tippet murder scene with gun in hand
and unequivocally identified the gunman
Alisa as Lee Harvey Oswald
these key eyewitnesses include cab
driver Williams Goggins Jr who saw
Oswald from as close as 12 feet Barbara
Davis and Virginia Davis who saw Oswald
cut across their lawn from a distance as
close as 20 feet saw him toss cartridge
cases in the bushes as he reloaded his
pistol they turned the cartridge cases
over the place and these were determined
to have come from the revolver that
Isles will pulled out in the Texas
theater but you'll never see Scoggins or
the Davis sisters-in-law or these
cartridge cases in JFK nor will you see
in JFK the truth about why Oswald was
arrested JFK would have the audience
believe that this in the words of
Costner and this is one of the most
distinct despicable
it aspects of JFK and it just tells
exactly what Oliver Stone is the arrest
of Oswald was the quote most remarkable
example of police intuition sinks the
Reichstag fire alluding to Hitler's rise
to power their repeated allusions to
Hitler in the film JFK would also have
the viewer believed that the police knew
someone knew Oswald was going to be
there and that the police used it as an
excuse for coming to the theater the
fact that Oswald did not purchase a 75
cent ticket this false claim is not new
it goes back to the very first of the
best-selling books attacking the Warren
Commission mark lanes rush to judgment
like lanes book the Warner Brothers film
covers up the testimony of Johnny Calvin
Brewer like Howard Brennan cab Doris
Goggins another one of the key witnesses
whose testimony I took while serving as
counsel the Warren Commission Brewer
managed a shoe store only eight blocks
away from the tempered murder shooting
he heard the shooting he heard police
coming down he heard police sirens
coming down the street approximately
fifteen minutes after the shooting he
saw a man later he died identified the
man as Oswald ducking to his shoe store
as a police sirens approached him and
the police sirens M the man left borough
became suspicious I asked him what
happened he says why I trailed him I
said why because I he looked funny his
hair was messed up he looked like he'd
been running brew a trail up to the
nearby Texas theater had the cashier
call the police
pointed Oswald when the police arrived
when the police approached nozzle he
pulled out a pistol which turned out to
be the tip of murder weapon all of this
is emitted in JFK they claim it's hipper
like police intuition that causes the
place to be there if any more examples
of wholesale emissions are needed to
show how JFK covers up the truth one can
turn to postal inspector Harry Holmes
the single most important witness on the
question of Jack Ruby on whether Jack
Ruby was can spiritually involved
virtually every
Sassa nation sensationalist who attacks
the Warren Commission claims that the
ultimate proof of the conspiracy is a
killing of Oswald by Ruby but like JFK
the omit and cover-up Holmes crucial
testimony homeles was involved in
helping trace the mailing of Oswald's
revolver and rifle to his post office
box in Dallas that he was running under
the alias AJ Hidell
and when I interrogated Holmes he told
me how on Sunday morning November 24th
two days after the assassination he was
on his way to church with his wife and
at the last minute he dropped her off
and decided to go down to the police
station to see if he could help his
friend captain Fritz the head of the
homicide section of the Dallas Police
Department with whom Homans had been
working when Holmes arrived the last
interrogation of Oswald was about to
begin before Oswald was to be
transferred to the County Jail fritz
invited Oswald Carberry Fritz invited
Holmes into the interrogation room
together with representatives of the FBI
and Secret Service because Holmes joined
the group and asked a number of
additional questions the interrogation
session was extended approximately 1/2
hour meanwhile Jack Ruby was on his way
downtown to wire money to one of his
employees he left the western union
office at approximately 11:17 a.m.
Central time according to the time stamp
on the Western Union money order and he
walked approximately one block to the
Dallas police station went down the
ramped and joined a group of newspaper
awaiting the transfer of Oswald who came
down a minute or two later
Oswald was killed at 11:21 a.m. had
postal inspector Holmes just gone on to
church that morning Oswald would have
been transferred long before Ruby ever
got downtown there never would have been
a Warren Commission and there were never
would be a David Belen standing before
you speaking today but don't never see
homes in JFK and you'll never read about
Holmes in any of the best-selling
conspiracy books about the assassination
nor will you hear in JFK about the other
fact
confirming that ruby was conspiratorial
II innocent such as the testimony of
Ruby's rabbi hillel Silverman who
repeatedly visited ruby in his jail cell
and was absolutely convinced based upon
his intimate conversations that ruby was
innocent of any conspiracy nor will you
ever learn that a Warren Commission
counsel an independent lawyer from Des
Moines by the name of David Belen after
being thwarted inside the Warren
Commission when he requested a polygraph
examination of Ruby went around the
Warren Commission and prevail upon
Ruby's rabbi to persuade Jack Ruby to
demand a lie-detector test nor will you
learn that in fact we did demand a
lie-detector test and that the results
of that lie-detector test confirmed
Ruby's conspiratorial innocence all of
this is covered up in JFK and in
virtually all of the other movies
television shows and best-selling
assassination literature which attacked
the credibility of Earl Warren of the
Warren Commission rabbi Silverman by the
way was never even interrogated by the
House Select Committee on assassinations
I might add that they also denied me the
opportunity of testifying in a public
hearing the repeated use of outright
lies is a third element that combines
with major misrepresentations and
emissions as assassination
sensationalists attack the Warren
Commission and Earl Warren here is a
typical example from JFK which
incorporates one of the central eyes
made by Lee Harvey Oswald during his
interrogation
Oswald was initially arrested for the
murder of officer Tippit and when he was
first interrogated he claimed he did not
own a rifle when he was shown the worldö
the well-known photograph of him holding
a rifle and pistol he claimed that he
knew a lot about photography and that
the picture was a fake with his head
being placed on someone else's body
that was a blatant lie and anyone who
objectively looks at the facts can
determine this because of the
manufacturing process of every camera
there are microscopic differences which
are just as distinctive as a fingerprint
if one has a negative it can be
scientifically determined whether that
negative came from that camera to the
exclusion of all other cameras in the
world
Roswell's arrest police discovered not
just the photographic print but the
negative of print and Oswald's camera
that negative came from Oswald's camera
the very fact that JFK adopts the lives
of Oswald and asserts that the picture
was part of a frame-up is a vivid vivid
example of how a movie dedicated to the
truth incorporates outright lies
together with misrepresentations and
emissions as a movie persuades its
audience at Earl Warren and the Warren
Commission covered up the truth the big
D dollars is a final link in the efforts
of water brothers caster and stone to
rewrite history I am amazed that so few
people have taken time to address the
common-sense aspects of how dollars have
have played such an important role in
the national controversy about the
assassination of President Kennedy as a
practical matter we are in the court of
world opinion and it is therefore
reasonable to draw upon the experience
of a courts and jury system in every
jury trial one of the central issues is
a credibility of each witness every
person who tries to persuade the jury of
hurry his version of the facts one of
the most important questions is whether
or not the witness has a financial
interest in the outcome of the
controversy I have made full final
financial disclosure from the very
beginning every dollar I have received
for my two books about the Kennedy
assassination November 22 1963 and final
disclosure has been turned over to
charity every dollar from lecture fees
every dollar for magazine and newspaper
articles has also been turned over to
charity it seems to me that when people
go around accusing Earl Warren of
participating in a cover-up of the truth
accusing Lyndon Johnson of being an
accessory after the fact
accusing elements of the CIA and the
prominent offense of plotting and
carrying out the assassination of
President Kennedy they have an
obligation to make full financial
disclosure so that the world knows how
much money they're making out of these
accusations it is most surprising to me
that the press has not come forward to
demand this kind of accounting Warner
Brothers caster and stone not only are
making millions but they have a piece of
the action
every
movie ticket every video they hope to
have our public schools purchase the
power of Warner Brothers has been aided
and abetted by a 15 million dollar
promotion budget and a vast public
relations machine that has helped break
down the barriers between news and
entertainment between truth of
revisionist fiction one of the most
dangerous aspects about the different
disinformation of JFK is how the
television networks in their quest for
ratings have helped promote the lies
about Earl Warren and the Warren
Commission here are some examples of how
this information is spread
everyone knows the three morning three
major television networks are in a
battle of ratings for the morning news
and entertainment programs when the
publicity machine of Warner Brothers was
preparing us war against the truth they
went to NBC and said that if NBC wanted
Kevin Costner one of the biggest names
of Hollywood to appear exclusively on
the Today Show and now that any other
competing Network show in December NBC
had a guarantee that JFK would have five
segments on five consecutive days
NBC agreed on the other hand when I
asked for five segments to respond I was
given only one here's another example
Oprah Winfrey decided to have Oliver
Stone in a program for a full hour
promoting the film before he appeared I
asked for equal time I was refused after
he appeared I asked for equal time again
Earl Warren and the Warren Commission
were not allowed one minute of Defense
you heard our chairman say this is a
truth that almost all of these
nationally televised programs the
audience is told is a part of giving
authenticity to the claims of the
assassination sensationalist that more
than three-fourths of Americans do not
believe the Warren Commission report but
if the only movies that audiences see
attacked the Warren Commission and if
nationally known shows like The Oprah
Winfrey Show in the Johnny Carson show
present only those who have a financial
interest in promoting misrepresentations
emissions and lies it is only natural to
expect
that the majority of Americans did not
believe that Oswald was a lone gunman
this leads into what I believe to be one
of the worst aspects of the media
blitzkrieg or the Warner Brothers film
JFK opens with a segment of news really
that footage from an address by
President Dwight Eisenhower when he
talked about the potential dangers of
the end of the power of the industrial
military complex from my perspective
this nation today faces an equally great
potential danger from the growing incest
within and among corporate giants
controlling the entertainment business
and the media business and the breaking
down of traditional barriers between
entertainment and news with the quest
for the almighty dollar coming first and
I might interject to say you go by the
plaque at the front of this National
Press Club and read what Joseph Pulitzer
has to say a cynical mercenary demagogue
at press will produce in time of people
as base as itself and that's what JFK is
producing Bill Moyers in a very
perceptive op-ed piece published in the
March 22 New York Times wrote how does a
reporter tell the difference anymore in
a world where Oliver Stone can be
praised for his quote journalistic
instincts close quote when he has Lyndon
Johnson tell a cabal of generals and
admirals get me elected and I'll get you
your war Rolling Stone dubs this all the
new news straight news the old news by
Rolling Stones definition is pooped
confused and broke in its place
a new culture of information is evolving
a heady concoction part Hollywood film
and TV part pop music and pop art mixed
with popular culture and celebrity
magazines tabloid telecasts cable and
home video and in packaging the new news
Hollywood can use its millions of
dollars to buy just about anything they
want to build their case for instance
over the years there have been four
panels of medical experts who have
examined the kennedy autopsy photographs
and x-rays a total of about 20 doctors
19 out of the 20 unequivocally state
that the material showed that all of the
shots came from the rear this confirms
what the physical
because they found the fragments of the
bullet that struck President Kennedy's
head - are complete enough to be
ballistically identifiable they came
from Oswald's rifle but there was a 20th
doctor who more recently has said there
was a simultaneous shot that hit the
head and exploded and disintegrated
leaving no trace when Oliver Stone
decided to produce JFK he used dollars
to buy the services of a medical
consultant guess which doctor he picked
perhaps the element irony in JFK is a
proclamation of mr. Koester Hitler said
the bigger the lie the more people will
believe it another illusion like why the
police converged on the Texas theater
mr. stone mr. Costner Warner Brothers
are proving all of this to be true and
making millions of dollars along the way
furthermore they want to spread the
disinformation of JFK into our public
schools and effect brainwashing students
through the power of a commercial film
and rewriting history the Hollywood way
and your chairman is correct for this
the film has received eight Academy
Award nominations for Hollywood to give
any Academy awarded this massive
misrepresentation of truth and character
assassination of Earl Warren would be
vivid evidence of the depth to which
Hollywood standards of integrity truth
and justice have fallen there are some
who assert in the face of the conspiracy
barrage by the mass media particularly
movies and televisions that we will
never know the truth that simply is not
accurate if one examines what judges
call the record as a whole not just the
one doctor but the twenty doctors not
just bits and pieces but the entire
record then beyond a reasonable doubt it
is clear that Lee Harvey Oswald was the
lone gunman who killed President Kennedy
wounded Governor Connally and killed
officer Tippit on that tragic afternoon
in Dallas November 22 1963 I want to
close on a personal note I am the
majority about which role spoken
era Warren has spoken one person in the
truth
my course has been steadfast from the
very first day in January 1954 when I
became one of the counsel of the Warren
Commission I will never forget the words
that Earl Warren said to all of us
truth is our only goal I took them at
his word as a matter of fact the most
controversial part of the Warren
Commission report the so called single
Bullet theory that the bullet that
passed through President Kennedy's neck
struck governor Connally grew out of an
attempt on my part to prove there was
more than one gunman and if we had more
time today I would tell you the inside
story of what led to the single Bullet
theory I follow the truth our only goal
standards of Erlewine when in 1975 I
investigated the CIA serving his
executive director of the Rockefeller
Commission I was the one who confronted
the CIA with no-holds-barred extracted
from them their admissions that they had
been engaged in assassination plots
against foreign leaders in peacetime and
when I returned to private life in the
last half of 1975 I filed Freedom of
Information Act requests to have all
remaining classified Warren Commission
documents and all CIA files pertaining
to the assassination of President
Kennedy reduce the public I have an
accent I have had access to all in a no
way to DES contradict to the conclusions
of the Warren Commission I asked for
help to educate America about how a
small group of assassination
sensationalists who have been making
huge amounts of money have through the
vehicle of misrepresentations emissions
and lies mislead this entire nation on
one of the major turning points of
modern American history it is what I
call the prostitution of the
assassination if they can do it in the
case of the assassination of President
Kennedy they can manipulate public
opinion on other issues of even greater
importance of war and peace I also ask
for your help to expose the corporate
incest between huge Hollywood empires
and the television networks and the
dangers that disposes to our democratic
society as they rewrite the truth to fit
their own mold I ask for your help to
show the tremendous
danger that this kind of revisionist
history poses to our democracy and to
place a nuclear perspective this media
manipulation and the threat it poses we
are faced with the tragic decline of the
relative importance of objective
reporting of news by media conglomerates
like Time Warner where at one time it
was Time magazine the printed Time
magazine that had dominance and today it
has Warner Brothers entertainment media
accompanied by multi-million dollar
bonuses paid to executives grounded in
maximizing dollars through entertainment
with wide appeal to mass audiences no
one knows better than I the dangers to a
free society that are posed by a CIA out
of control but from my perspective I see
an equally great or perhaps even greater
long-range danger to our democratic
institutions of government with the
increasing control by the entertainment
industry over our national media
particularly television when
misrepresentations emissions allies are
so effective that they can destroy the
credibility of a great chief justice and
the Commission he chaired and
concurrently contribute to the
destruction of trust and confidence of
citizens in their democratic
institutions of government this can have
grave consequences for our nation's
future in the epilogue of final
disclosure I write of Citizen Trust as
the mortar that holds the structure of a
democratic government together
if trust erodes our democracy can
crumble and in the wake of erosion of
citizen trust as an outgrowth of Vietnam
Watergate the excesses of the CIA
iran-contra the savings loan scandal and
most recently the rubber gate scandals
of Congress we can ill afford to have
citizens become so cynical of the
government that they do not even believe
the findings of an interdependent
Commission shared by a former Chief
Justice of the United States with a
reputation of real lorne this has been
one of the major motivating factors for
my continuing defensive role warned the
war intrusion and the truth about the
assassination of President Kennedy
though I am just one
Penant lawyer from Des Moines Iowa and
though my talents and abilities may be
limited
I am nevertheless an optimist by Nature
at the end of final disclosure I wrote
that the truth has a long fuse and
ultimately it prevails
please help shorten the length of that
fuse by digging the way journalists are
supposed to dig in exposing the more
than 100 major misrepresentations
emissions and lies that have been
perpetrated by Warner Brothers Costner
and stone what they have done is just
plain evil and intelligent people who
care for our country should not let them
get away with it particularly when they
are now trying to invade our public
schools with their lies I call for your
help in this battle for the truth
because I believe in walter Lippmann
standard that the press must put the
truth first and because I so fervently
believe in another one of Earl Warren's
favorite sayings the only thing
necessary for evil to exist is for good
people to remain silent thank you
I'd be happy to take some questions I
would ask them of you thank you while we
were here today I'm told to Senator
David Boren of Oklahoma and
representative Lewis Stokes who headed
the house assassination committee today
made plain their intention to open the
closed files into the assassination do
you support such a move what is likely
to emerge from the opening of the files
I support such a move I try to do it
1975 I can tell you what first of all if
every single piece of paper every single
document were laid out it would
absolutely have no bearing on the facts
that Lee Harvey Oswald was a lone gunman
who killed Kennedy wounded Connolly and
killed him what is likely to happen and
there are only about 2% of Warren
Commission files that have not been
released they've fallen for brief
categories ones involving privacy people
that made allegations that someone else
was involved in the assassination
investigated and not disclosed for
Madison privacy of the allegations made
like you were sitting in a restaurant in
Oklahoma City when someone's claimed to
heard you say you're going to kill the
president questions about matters of
protection of the president questions
about sources and methods whereby they
thought if they would disclose
particular items of foreign intelligence
for instance that that would literally
drop the well perhaps put someone's life
in danger I thought in 1975 that 11
years had passed and they could release
it it seems to me that the CIA will
never release everything boggling if
they're CIA said they would release
everything people wouldn't believe it
but and that's one of the reasons I talk
about trust and confidence in government
when I investigated the CIA by the way I
threatened them with polygraph exams if
to make sure that they would tell me the
truth I didn't have authority to do it
but it's Rettendon anyway but in any
event you're likely to get the release
of tens of thousands of pages and it'll
be interesting but it won't change the
conclusion I support it I hope they do
it and I'll look forward it
we have several questions along this
line how do you know that either the FBI
or CIA did not withhold or distort
information relating to the Kennedy
assassination isn't an investigation
like conducting discovering the practice
of law so that you must say that you've
had access to all the files on the
assassination that the agencies hadn't
hidden or destroyed I don't trust the
FBI I don't trust the CIA
I don't trust very many people in this
country except my son Tom I hope he
trusts me that's one of the reasons it
was so important to have independent
people outside of government and
although we initially started with
looking at the FBI files and everything
else we did our own independent
investigation on the scene interrogation
of witnesses we found people that the
FBI had never found that the Dallas
Police Department ever found
what you do see though is this is that
every lawyer every practical lawyer
knows that when you get a hold of a case
you start getting some semblance of the
of the validity of the testam of the
witnesses who you believe who you don't
believe if everything were perfect you
know something's wrong one of the things
I wanted the Warren Commission to do
would be to have the report in two
volumes including major transcript
testimony so the people would see the
authenticity of what happened when when
you read the the writing of when you
read what someone said in the fifth
floor below the assassination window
three employees and one of them said
that the vibrations actually put some
plaster in his head is it part of the
ceiling plaster fell down a little bit
and Ellen said well you know what I said
and I said no he says I said no [ __ ]
but when you hear that kind of
authenticity of testimony you get it
from the witnesses you don't get it for
reports and people say the Warren
Commission relied reports I didn't rely
on FBI reports I found a lot of
inaccuracies I relied upon evaluation of
all the evidence and it wasn't perfect
but who have six people for instance
that identify Oswald as a different
murder murder
you see Scoggins as he says he sees this
man headed toward his cab
Clark and he ducks down because he's
afraid he's going to come near the cab
and he sees them as close as 12 feet you
see five other people had the same thing
and you have with this a ballistic
evidence to say by god he did kill tip
it so it's the overall record from the
witnesses themselves in the physical
evidence
several people want you to answer on
specific conspiracy theories in your
criticism a questioner says you fail to
mention the colorized blow-up of Mary
Mormons photo showing a man in a
policeman's uniform firing a rifle from
the grassy knoll your response please
that rumor is rampant it's just not true
there is no one fired from the grassy
knoll and Mary Mormons photograph but
I'll tell you a story
Mary Moorman is with her friend Jean
Hill Jean hills testimonies in
transcript formula we published 26
volumes of testimony exhibits with the
Warren Commission and Jean Hill
testified that she was a closest person
to the presidential limousine when the
fatal shot struck about 15 or 20 feet
away and when we asked her I did I
wasn't one who targeted when she was
asked to describe what she saw well she
saw the Kennedys in the backseat and
between them there was a fuzzy white dog
well I don't think anyone believes there
was a fuzzy white god but people's uh
people's memories are inaccurate there
is no there is no a gunman in Mary
Moorman picture now people have blown it
up one of the people that talks about
this is a man growing that goes around
and one time said that there was a
gunman in a ornamental tree and a tree
in the grassy knoll area and when the
Rockefeller Commission days we examined
that tree was 8 feet high with a truncus
feet thick that supposedly there was a
gunman in that window I'm going to add
one other thing no and I think this is
awfully important for people to
understand you got to take a look at all
these things with an aspect of common
sense who do you think wanted to find
out more than anyone else in the world
who killed President Kennedy the answer
that question probably is Robert Kennedy
his brother the Attorney General who
headed the Justice Department oversaw
the FBI and had a liaison with the
Warren Commission working full-time
his name was hard Willard's he's a
here in Washington one of his partners
Ron green is in the room here if there
was triangulation if there was a second
gunman my gosh
Bobby Kennedy would have wanted to get
that person that helped kill his brother
but no one seems to want to talk about
common sense the [ __ ] picture story's
just false well here's another one in
the current crop how about the new book
mortal error contains a ballistic theory
- the third shot the head shot that
struck the president was as a result of
an accidental discharge of a secret
service weapon you know I can be here
for the next year there isn't one
question that anyone can raise about the
facts of who killed President Kennedy
that I cannot fully respond to and
document if you give me time I may not
have it on NBC I may not have it any
other places but I'll answer every
single question I'll tell you bout that
one look at the overall record you got
the portions of a bullet that struck the
president's head the single most
traumatic experience in my professional
career was when I was at the FBI lab and
held in my hand the ballistically the
two ballistically identifiable portions
of pieces of metal that kill the
president that ended a human life ready
to examine him under a comparison
microscope with a test bullet people can
say that there is a Secret Service
accident this chart you think someone
would have seen that happen but apart
from whether someone did or didn't say
it it got the bullet that did it take a
look at the overall record several
questioners say that in the movie JFK
during the trial scenes an illustration
used to show the course of the third
bullet then I guess the magic bullet
seems incredible it shows it taking a
lot of twists and turns
did that bullet take the course
described by Costner was there a fourth
shot well
that's the testimony of the 20th doctor
but I'll tell you since you've asked the
question I'll tell you how this thing
about theory developed I was a young
trial lawyer from Moines Iowa Washington
the last thing the road you want to do
is to spend months there and come up
with the same conclusions the FBI that
the first bullet struck Kennedy the
second bullet Connally the third bullet
Kennedy and I followed her a warrant I
left no stone unturned to find the truth
well in the Zapruder film we numbered
each frame and slides a fatal shot was
framed 3:13 you couldn't see when
President Kennedy was first hit because
his head disappears behind a freeway
sign and it reappears at a frame with
his hands coming up to his throat at
frame 225 the Cameron we had the
Zapruder cameraman at eighteen point
three frames a second so if Kennedy was
doing us at frame 225 maybe half a
second earlier he was hit say around
frame 215 or 216 you couldn't see
exactly where Connally was hit now
Connally basically says that he was hit
by the second bullet I reasoned that if
I could prove that the rifle could not
be fired fast enough to have one
rifleman do it all we had the rifle that
the FBI said at that time couldn't be
fired faster than two and a quarter
seconds it actually could but they told
us to in a quarter second she multiplied
two and a quarter times eighteen point
three frames a second that's about 40
frames but it couldn't tell even with
the best photography experts in the
world at the time where Colley was him
one weekend I used to go home to Moines
every other weekend but one weekend I
was working in Ellison I got a great
idea
Governor Kylie's physicians all agree
that he was hit by one bullet
JFK doesn't ever tell you that the
bullet entered his back exited his right
chest went through the back was rest X
at the front of the wrist and a
superficial wound in the leg and I said
he had to be sitting in a certain
position to take that wound and so I
contacted Secret Service in Dallas and I
said have governor colleagues physicians
reconstruct his position to show how he
had to be CID and see it I sitting to
take the wound that he did and they did
that and I got back with the support of
film and I said okay where could he be
sitting in this film
take this kind of a hit and lo and
behold commencing at around frame 200 or
so he could take the hitter to ten
whatever was but he couldn't take the
hit after frame to 40 and if Kennedy was
hit at frame to 15 or to 20 and Kylie
was not hit after frame to 40 and the
camera ran at eighteen point three
frames a second a maximum of a second or
second a quarter there had to be a
second gunman and I called home that
night to my wife I said Connie I think
I've done it I think I've proved there
was a second gunman well the only thing
wrong was that there wasn't any sign of
the bullet that went through president
canning his neck and so we did some
wound ballistic tests through the
Edgewood Arsenal what happens to a rifle
bullet that passes through a neck this
way how fast is it enter how fast does
it exit we used goat meat of 20 percent
gelatin compound different experiments
it entered about 1,900 feet a second
exited at 1,800 feet a second at that
speed it had to eat either caused great
damage to the car which it didn't or hit
someone in the car well then we
reconstructed motorcade frame by frame
down Dealey Plaza and lo and behold
commencing around frame to 7:00 to 10:00
or thereabouts through a single lens
reflex camera with the rifle scope
Connally and Kennedy are right on line
and so we had to conclude I had to
conclude that my cycling gummin theory
was no good and that the bullet indeed
that went through president Kenny's neck
start governor Connally that's the way
it happened that's the way the signal
that redeveloped in Arlen Specter was
the one that examined the doctors to
help develop the theory I suppose if I
never would have done this who knows
what would happen in a but that's what
that's what happened
there's a new movie out Jack Ruby do you
believe that Jack Ruby acted alone and
independently all postal inspector
Holmes was part of the conspiracy David
belen was part of the conspiracy to
cover up you know if you go ahead and
enumerate all the so-called conspirators
you're going to have fifty or hundred
people my observation washing you know
better than I don't think three people
can keep a secret here but maybe they
can't senator Baker could tell us how
many people could keep a secret here
Jack Ruby if you want to read some
fascinating literature if you go to the
library to read to pick up my first book
November 22 1963 I did that book because
of request that Harrison Salisbury
thought I ought to do it it had the
heart of the transcript testimony that I
thought should have been included in the
Warren Commission report and you read
what Jack Ruby says a Jack Ruby
basically claims that that on Saturday
he had seen a rabbi giving a eulogy
about Kennedy survived all the wars and
then came back to be shot in the back
I heard that mrs. Kennedy would have to
come back to testify and basically he he
you know he never thought about it but
he carried a pistol round with him and
when when he was in the basement when
the Jack Ruby when Oswald was brought by
he just impulsively went forward to and
killed him and supposedly to save mrs.
Kennedy ordeal of coming forward to a
trial the lie detector test corroborated
then I think that there was another
reason why that rabbi Silverman told me
that if I write another book I'll
probably say that for the book but he
was not conspiratorial involved and it's
a happenstance the reason he was not
conspiracy involved is that if he were
the press were told that be down after
ten o'clock if you want to go ahead and
make sure you see house well transferred
and he wouldn't have waited to come down
when he did and there's another
common-sense thing Mafi hid people don't
kill their targets in the middle of a
police station where they're going to be
apprehended and thrown in jail and you
got to have some common sense just like
with Robert Kenney thing he was not
conspiratorial Aldon you know I'm
other things rabbi Hillel sovereign
doesn't if you were to talk if you were
to have him or just ask him that
question he'd reached the same
conclusion a couple of related questions
list a questionnaire asserts to a degree
the secrecy and occasional carelessness
of the Warren Commission and law
enforcement encouraged conspiracy
theories what would you have done
differently and why were some parts of
the papers closed to the public I agree
with that that there were mistakes made
I almost resigned from the Warren
Commission when Earl Warren made the
decision not to release the autopsy
photographs on x-rays my position was at
officer Tippit swittel couldn't withhold
evidence from the public concerning the
murder of her husband so why should the
Kennedy family be treated differently
Robert Kennedy prevailed upon Chief
Justice Warren to do this I decided to
say because I felt that there isn't
anyone that would do a more independent
job than I and I did have an obligation
to find the truth that I started there
were mistakes made inside the Warren
Commission apart from not releasing the
photographs and x-rays they first of all
didn't even have the photographs and
x-rays that the testimony when these
doctors were there the Warren Commission
I think made mistakes they did not
examine Marina Oswald thoroughly enough
League Rankin fine gentlemen General
Counsel is one that examined her Earl
Warren I think had some feelings of pity
for she was a widow in a strange country
her husband had been charged with
killing the president killing a police
officer the two lawyers that were
heavily involved that whole area of
Oswald's background Bert Jenner was no
longer living and Jim Leibler who's now
a professor at UCL ossicles should have
really done that the whole area of
secrecy in government is something that
really troubles me and that's why in
1975 I filed Freedom of Information Act
requests having seen everything that the
CIA had sure would disclose sources and
methods but they had withheld evidence
from the law information that they
should have done the evidence of the CIA
assassination plots I don't condone what
they did what I can tell you is that
despite that we were able to find the
truth that Lee Harvey Oswald was an
oncoming before I asked the final
question I'd like to present you with a
certificate of appreciation
for appearing here today and a National
Press Club coffee mug I just like to
observe that Oliver Stone has both
himself since he spoke here to many
people there's many more questions than
we can answer here today but many of
them run along the same lines in
different directions
would you discuss Fidel Castro's role in
the assassination or the possibility of
KGB involvement and was what was
Oswald's motivation was he was he was he
possibly fleeing to one a foreign nation
that's a wonderful question it's a great
question to close with I have my basic
theories about what the motive was he is
that for the assassination I have really
not publicly discussed this because of
people don't believe me when I say that
oswald was a lone gunman it's irrelevant
what my theories are because they all
depend upon what I know to be the fact
that Oswald was a lone gunman I don't
think the KGB was involved in this as
for the involvement of Castro
I don't think Castro told Oswald to kill
President Kennedy I will say no more as
time except what I would suggest you've
asked a lot of questions of me and I
wish we had time for more I wish that
when you ask questions of Oliver Stone
you take some time you can find about
Johnny Calvin brewer in the Warren
Commission report you can find about the
photographic evidence commencing a page
597 I believe the Warren Commission
report on that camera you have to ask
some questions why mr. stone do you why
monitor brothers do you lie about Johnny
Calvin Brewery news illusion Hitler
destroyed this country come forward with
the appearance of being patriotic to
release everything when you're lying and
destroying this trust and confidence and
in attacking or Lorne what about the
tippet murder witnesses that you covered
up ask them these questions as you ask
me these questions and do your homework
when you're doing and when you do and
when there is a general consensus that
indeed the Warren Commission was right
that Lee Harvey Oswald was a lone gunman
invite me back here and I'd be happy to
answer those questions of where I think
the motivation was and what collateral
facts and evidence
as to why Lee Harvey Oswald killed
President Kennedy and there are some
very fascinating aspects of that thank
you
thank you that concludes today's
luncheon thank you